this morning 8-2-6 an Innovative writing
program co-founded by one of the
nation's most celebrated authors molding
the next generation of storytellers
826 Valencia was formed in San Francisco
by Dave Eggers and Nineveh Caligari it's
now expanded into nine chapters around
the country serving more than 350
000 students each year the program
focuses on making sure as many students
as possible get one-on-one attention and
that they see their names and stories in
Prince
and have some fun along the way
walk into 826 Valencia Street in San
Francisco and you'll find what's
believed to be the only store in the
world entirely dedicated to selling
pirate supplies
but get beyond that and you soon realize
the point of this place is not to Hawk
fake gold coins
it is to deliver very real dreams I
wanted the place to be weird we wanted
it to be kind of homey and strange and
totally unexpected and have a sense of
humor because kids are so funny they're
so strange and funny and we so rarely
Embrace that and reflect it back to them
a pirate's life for me the weird
storefronts have become a staple at 826
writing centers around the world from
secret agents in Chicago okay are you
guys ready to go through the secret
passageway
to superheroes in Brooklyn a time travel
mart in Los Angeles and a woodland
creature Outfitter store at their newest
location in San Francisco when you
create a place that is profoundly
beautiful and wonderful and surprising
and young people walk through that space
it's a transformative experience for
them and it sends them the message
something's going to be different here
over the past 20 years 826 has become
the largest youth Writing Center in the
world if you could talk to your ancestor
what would you ask them matching up
volunteer tutors
ask them what were they eating at the
old times oh really with students in
under-resourced communities all free of
charge
founded by Dave Eggers and Nineveh
kalagare the current director is beaten
azerian a former School principal I
think that's what 826 does so well is it
says students voices matter here's the
support you need as a teacher as a young
person in our system and then let's
publish you Edgar's first major success
in the publishing world was the Memoir a
heartbreaking Work of Staggering Genius
the book turned him into a literary
Superstar
and he soon discovered he knew lots of
others who were looking for ways to
contribute to their communities
kaligari was a teacher working in a
school overwhelmed with too many
students I had 146 students and any one
given time I never had enough time to
give them the attention I thought they
deserved and I just knew that teachers
out there would be super thirsty for
this service and and that was true Jimmy
and Latifah were two of the students
there when we visited High person
reading this I'll be telling you in my
own words how I see the future they
shared some of their own published works
on a lonely land I care for my grandma
says Mom Grandpa and myself because
they're my family do you think it's cool
to see your name in print yes I mean you
get it it's a nice feeling it's kind of
reflects it's a flex yeah it very much
is a flex yeah there's a confidence and
a calm that comes over a published Young
author because they feel like I got it
right I put it on paper it's in this
book that's my truth it's there
permanently Osvaldo Marquez Gomez is a
former student he's been published 11
times what did 826 do that the schools
couldn't it was that one-on-one
intention I had a hard time asking for
help so once a tutor is visual like
visually sitting there and like what's
going on like what are you processing
what questions do you have so like that
proactive like one-on-one attention is I
feel like that goes a long way it's
pretty wild to think like you see the
student 15 20 years ago and then he's my
boss now yeah he's your boss yeah on the
board sits on the board of directors
Oswaldo now helps oversee a writing
program at a time when there were 2500
documented cases of books being banned
last year an all-time high
gers recently joined that list he was
really surprised I had to that my book
The Circle was banned in a school
district in Rapid City South Dakota I
had to look back at the book to figure
out what there was and that I don't
remember anything and it would have been
objectionable but I was there a couple
weeks ago and talking to teachers and
talking to students and we had amazing
sessions and the teachers are incredibly
resilient they're finding ways around it
is not meant to replace the education
system but supplement it in ways most
schools can't
and it's about the people who are
willing to give their time to help these
kids find a voice
and in the process
maybe ReDiscover their own
[Music]
what the 826 tutors taught me and what
Dave has brought to the world is this
huge reminder that learning is also
joyful and I think that public school
teachers are doing their best in in
difficult circumstances and I do think
when there's so much stress and strain
on that system that it is it is
difficult to remember that that learning
can be joyful and that it can be driven
by love and kindness
um what a great reminder I would try to
find despite all the stresses and
everything else and joy yeah in these
places and just no matter what these
these people have accomplished here Dave
you know whatever it's only important if
they can give back
and instead of taking that and giving it
back and passing it on to the next
Generation that's a wonderful thing it
is and so is this it's a shipwreck that
was underwater for more than 500 years
so it's taken kind of time to dry out
two decades after its Discovery this
remarkable wreck is ready for its
close-up that's next on CBS Saturday
morning
foreign
[Music]
welcome back and what is really cool
Jeff about this I love the storefronts
and all of it because I'm looking behind
you so it's gorgeous that alone this is
a sparkling creature Outfitters I mean
but that alone Sparks so much creativity
yeah child and anyone really so my
question is how do kids sign up for this
or is it you know it's they have limited
resources for this in terms of
availability so how do we how big if
parents are interested for their kids
you go to the website a26's website and
check it out see if it's in the area you
know they're not in every city in the
country
um but they are international now as
well there are international locations
but I asked them I said what you know
what's your goal for the next 20 in 20
years from now so 40 years in they said
we would love to be able to provide
services to every single under-resourced
child in this country that is wonderful
which it is wonderful and it's I mean
it's it's a massive goal yeah it's also
ambitious and it is you know know with
Public Schools it is a huge problem
across the country if you talk to
anybody who public schools that are in
well-taxed areas versus not well even in
well-taxed areas the numbers are high of
classroom size but at least the funding
is there yeah in those other areas it's
it's awful what we see though is that
these programs work right they make a
difference and these kids can provide
them and Thrive and don't we want our
children to do that you open them up